hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game it's from the second
round of the tepe sigma chess tournament
current currently being played in malmo
sweden uh it's actually nerigasi versus
sol salem yesterday we've uh seen uh
very nice games played by both of them
we've only shown the game eric ac played
in his game against alexa shiro of a
very very nice um uh double-edged fight
uh and uh slim defeated david navarra
and now this game you guys will enjoy it
features one of your favorite lines um
uh or rather favorite ways to to counter
the karaoke fantasy variation uh against
the karo khan uh so let's dive straight
into it uh erigasi uh has the white
pieces and he opens with e4
we have c6 uh going for the karo khan d
for d5 and now arjun goes for f3 this is
the fantasy variation against the karo
khan and it's not extremely popular but
it is very popular here knight to c3 e5
any captures and d5 are the absolute top
choices also knights to d2
is a well-known line but f3 it's like
the the fifth most popular option so
let's see how can black deal with this
and the white's idea is pretty clear he
wants black to capture here and then
after f captures an e4 white will keep
the the strong center not the usual
knight the c3 then black captures and
then we get a knight into the center so
this way okay we don't have a knight in
the center very early on in the game but
we are saying we want to keep the center
pretty much forever so d captures on e4
we have f captures and now e5 makes
sense as um the pawn is in c6 so white
cannot advance the pawn to d5 knight to
f3 and now bishop to g4 pinning the
knight here c3 as strengthening the
center and knight to d7 now so you can
see white accomplished what white wanted
uh the strong center is there uh we have
bishop to d3 knight g2 f6 and now
arjun castles we have bishop to d6 and
now uh the position has been reached
before there are uh a couple of moves
that are known in this position the the
most notable notable game uh from 2020
uh fabiano corona versus
knights the a3 was played by fabi the
game ended in the draw it was from the
from the norway chess tournament but
here we have a move that has never been
played before and that is king the h1 so
already as of move 9 we have a
completely new game uh let's see how uh
salis uh deals with this so here uh he
castles king side uh bishop to g5 now
pinning the knight here and h6 with
bishop to h4 and queen to c7 unpinning
and now we can move the knight but also
if black captures there's also a knight
here so we don't have to mess up our
pawn structure knight b to b2 uh
developing and now b5 we have rook to c1
a nice developing square for the rook as
if the c file opens up
we are already x-raying the black queen
we have a6 and now pawn to a4 uh knight
to h5 now with idea so bringing the
knight over to f4 attacking the bishop
on d3 h3 challenging black's bishop and
not knight to f4 the bishop on d3 is
undefended
uh so you we are using this um maneuver
to our advantage uh bishop back to b1
and now the ship captures on f3 we have
rook characters and now knight back to
g6 attacking the bishop here bishop to
f2 and now pawn to c5 so here you can
see that black did very well black can
be very happy with himself uh we are
attacking the d5 d4 pawn twice and
black should not have a worry in the
world so knight to f1 adding another
defender to the d4 pawn
and here what do you play here with
black it's a very very tricky position
and you're
[Music]
well
you kind of do want to capture here this
is what you've been playing for
but in the game c4 was played and this
will be uh this will be troublesome for
black so what you play here of course if
captures captures then your queen is
attacked you can move the queen and okay
the game continues it's uh the position
is as it is now okay let's say after
some b5 or d5 or or some of the moves
but for example if d5 then c6 might
become a nice outpost for white so white
will always be a little bit better in
all of these lines
uh but there is a move you can play and
that is b captures an a4 that's just a
very very disgusting engine move it's
like a slap in the face you know
very very few people would actually play
this but it does make sense you win a
pawn uh you force uh the the b two pawn
to remain on b2 so
if you move to b3 then black just
captures it and of course you cannot
capture with the queen because if the
queen captures then c captures on d4 is
very strong now you can't capture with
the c pawn because the rook on c1 hangs
so b captures an a4 although looking
very weird it is uh in in fact fine
however after c4 this will not make it a
problem for black and it's uh
a similar similar idea in pretty much
all the other openings if you abandon
the struggle for the center then you
will you will definitely pay the price
they say that he who controls the center
will win the game and now this is uh
this is a very massive center and black
is not contesting it in any way so here
knights to e3 now the knight is coming
to d5 or to f5 depending on what black
plays probably to d5 the queen is on c7
rook a to d8 and now queen to c2 now you
have to be even more careful if the
position opens up let's say d cap e
captures on d4 we're going to push the
pawn
let's say the knight is in here now you
can easily imagine a nice checkmate
happening here so rook f2 e8 we have
rook to f1 now shifting the attention to
the f file
and now we have knight d to f8
uh knights to d5 attacking the black
queen here queen to c8 and now bishop to
e3 so you can see how arjun is placing
all of his pieces into the attack the f7
pawn is attacked so everything is uh
attacked very nicely here uh so now
after bishop to e3 the df7 pawn is
hanging so we have to do something about
this knights the h8 defending the pawn
and now comes a captures on b5 a
captures and of course b3 this is how we
undermine black's setup uh bishop back
to b8 and now b captures on c4 we have b
captures on c4 and queen to f2 now
with a triple attack on the uh f7 square
so queen to b7 adding a defender and now
queen to h4 so how do you defend this a
bishop captures on h6 is is a move that
will definitely happen then we if if
black captures we gain control over the
f6 square queen captures on h6 this will
be a very quick game rook is coming to
g3
not not even fun to look at so here we
have knight f to g6 uh bringing in a
defender here also attacking the queen
here queen to g4 and then now comes
queen to c6 and this is a a very uh odd
decision in a
in a very very uh critical situation
here offering a queen trade is probably
probably best but of course white will
never trade white will always just bring
the queen to h5 uh knights to b for now
attacking the queen and now again queen
to d6 here again queen to d7 or queen to
c8 it does make sense we want to offer a
queen trade
and then white would decide whether
whether queen to h5 was better whether
trading was better but
definitely the way to go after queen to
d6 uh there is one problem here
black's idea is fine but there is one
move that completely uh cripples black's
position and leaves you with a
completely winning position so feel free
to pause the video here and try to
figure out this idea for um arjun while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that e
captures on d4 is a terrible threat and
if you've spotted this then of course
you've spotted the move that wins the
game and that of course is pawn to d5 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are an exceptional positional
player uh the problem is if you play
something like let's say h4 you want to
play h5 just eat captures on d4 and
that's it we're attacking the bishop
threatening checkmate here and if bishop
to f4 we can just play knight captures
rook captures and now let's see in ig6
we attacked the rook and everything just
falls apart for white you're going to
either suffer severe material loss or
you will get checkmated if the rook
moves so d5 stops all of this and now
what we have here i remember when we
said that the blacks c4 might not have
been so great a bit of an
anti-positional idea but now with the
queen side completely closed with the uh
center of the board completely closed
and the white also having a past deep on
uh all of the attention of the game
turns to the king side and that is where
white is definitely stronger so here
bishop to c7 uh now comes bishop to a2
we're going to bring our bishop into the
game uh and there's really nothing black
can do to prevent this so here we have
knight to f4 bishop captures on c4 and
now knight h to g6
okay so the knight on f4 is very nicely
placed uh but it doesn't matter knight
to c6 we attacked the rook here rook to
a8 and now pawn to g3 challenging the
knight and uh
wha what can you do here there's really
no square for this knight it's uh just
uh it's just trapped there on f4 so here
rook to a4 was played attacking the
bishop now comes bishop to b3 attacking
the rook and rook captures an e4 so here
uh solid knows that he's in a very very
tough situation and he has to uh pull a
really huge rabbit out of a hat to get
out of this one and here he's doing his
very best rook captures on e4 is one
such idea uh the idea is that if the
knight is captured then we're going to
play e captures on f4 and black still
has a very firm grip on the position
after the bishop moves we're gonna play
rook to e2 it's uh okay it's not uh it's
not great but um uh you know he's
fighting back the the two connected soon
to be connected past pawns will be tough
to handle but um you know uh it is of
course winning for white but it's a it
gives black some chances however here
arjun arjun just says queen to f5 we're
gonna attack the rook and the rook has
no squares now so rook captures on e3 we
have to grab something at least rook
captures and now queen to c5 attacking
the rook here rook after e1 and now
knight captures on d5 removing the
defender of the knight and c6 but queen
to d7 and here everything is hanging the
knight here is hanging the bishop is
hanging if the knight moves the rook is
hanging so what can you play here
rook the e6 going after the knight here
and now it seems like you are very very
close to winning this game uh but you
are also uh well very close that
uh well just blundering all of your
advantage away so what would you capture
the night with or maybe that's not even
what you were considering but capturing
the knight is is definitely the way to
go now you could play knights to d8
that's one way to do it but queen
captures and e5 is just uh much more
forcing if the ship captures on d8 then
you allow this knight to f8 trickery and
now black sort of bounces back now the
queen is attacked and you have to play
something you're going to play check uh
check the the black king and after rook
captures now you're going to play queen
to c6 save your bishop here and after
queen captures bishop captures let's say
g6 black is still in the game and black
will
try try and fight this however after
queen captures on d5
it is uh
a little bit different but also much
different because now queen captures and
c6 was played queen captures rook
captures on c6 and now there's a
beautiful finishing touch rook to f1 now
the f7 pawn is hanging and there's
really no good way to defend it because
if knight to h8 uh you're already down
material you're down the exchange okay
you're up upon but you're down the
exchange and you're gonna be in a very
passive position bishop d5 we're gonna
challenge the rook and now you either
play rook to f6 uh or or if you don't
want that then we're just gonna close
the position like this and black will
suffer
so
sally went rook to f6 right away now he
offers a rook trade but now okay rook
captures g captures and rook to d3 now
you're just up the exchange and black
will have to
try and figure something out against uh
yeah well it's four points against three
but still it's it's not going to be
possible to defend this knight to f6
knight to f8 we have g4 king to g7 now
comes bishop to d5 uh bishop to b6 and
now pawn to c4 we have knights to g6
rook to b3 now
bishop to d4 and now rook to b7 going
after the f7 pawn so again if you want
to play knight stay h8 you can but um
that's uh i mean that's your knight will
remain there for for the rest of the
game so here of course it's better just
to give up one pawn to try and uh keep
the position active knight to f4 was
played king h2 now we have king to g6
and king to g3 still waiting with the
capture on f7 knights the e2 with check
king to f3 we have knights to g1 check
king to g2 knights to e2 and now pawn to
h4 we have h5 now comes bishop captures
an f7 king to h6 and bishop to d5 and he
was in this position animal 58 that
sally salim resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here he's
done too much material and there's just
no good way of playing this uh no
fortresses are possible here if you just
capture then uh well we we have many
options but bishop to e4 is the main one
and this is probably why uh sally uh
resigned so fast because now there is no
move whatsoever that black can play at
uh
prevent getting checkmated is just uh
well it's just a really really
tough position to be in okay you could
try something like knight to f4 with
check but after the king moves for
example king h2 knight to g6 now and now
okay the knight has to remain there
we're gonna play king g3 capture here
and well it's just completely completely
passive but probably why he resigned he
he saw that after captures bishop here
and there's just no more nothing to play
for anymore uh so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it might even use
this one as a thumbnail as it's uh well
or maybe not as it didn't happen in the
game i'll give it i'll give it a thought
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it a very very nice victory
by arjun nireishi who is now on two out
of two and he's getting very very uh
close to that 2700 mark so we'll see if
he will be he he might i mean of course
if he has such a brilliant tournament he
might even uh get it in this event but
that would be
that would be nothing short of uh
spectacular if something like that would
happen uh but yeah uh once again i hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank uh paul hinomund uh michael
colbert uh asher fine uh joshua hadley
and queen c for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the chess world
such as this wonderful game here uh so
yeah thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day